today we're going to have a program in
continuing in this series inspired by
and
about children and I thank him for his
continued collaboration in this lecture
series on biology individuality and the
humanities just keep you aware of coming
events Bob will be speaking in here to
Whitney on next Monday at 4 p.m. on a
new paradigm in brain imaging in the
series to come in the next semester
we'll have talks by our own good writer
in EB and systems biology Institute
Peter Godfrey Smith from City University
and Allen love from university Minnesota
in the spring so today it's my pleasure
to introduce today a speaker and
Thursday speaker Paul privets Paul is a
professor in the Department of
Philosophy at the University of Sydney
and at the ESRC Center for genomics in
society at the University accident his
biologists are a philosopher of biology
and psychology and has broad interests
in the history of ethology or the study
of animal behavior the philosophy of
emotion evolutionary developmental
biology the concept of the gene genetics
and philosophy and the enigmas of human
behavior Paul was educated at Cambridge
Janet Australian National University is
a highly productive author he's the
author of three books including genetics
and philosophy sex and death and
introduction to the philosophy of
biology those are the hot topics and
what emotions really are the problem of
psychological categories Paul is also
the author of three edited volumes and
over 40 journal articles and 30 other
book chapters so it's been productive
often when I started when we started
exploring this this speakers for this
series I enjoyed learning that Paul is
working on both ethology and evo-devo or
developmental language technology and I
thought I was nearly the only one
which those secret Paul has synthesized
at his various interest in his work so
for example he brings his interest in he
bode bow to his work on on my human
nature and the development Falls website
includes a picture of a conversation
with Ernst Meier in which Paul tells me
Ernst informed him that he was happy to
have given his recent book a good review
but he wanted to take that opportunity
to correct many of the errors and
probably talking about new research at
the interface of the biological
information and evolutionary causation
and I think a typical of work that is
both relevant to cutting-edge and new
issues in biology and hardcore
philosophy of science and his talk is
entitled information and living systems
now just to give you a heads up he will
be returning Thursday here at 4 o'clock
to be joined by a good partner and a
conversation about the order of life and
and you are welcome to join us after
today's talk for a reception
well thank you Richard for that kind
introduction and thank you very much for
the invitation to come here and speak so
I'm going to do something which for
those in the room who've worked on this
topic you're you'll read this as so many
people have started a talk on this topic
by saying something about the old
dispute between preformation and
epigenesis so here is somebody in the
50s famous biologist Conrad Warrington
drawing his own analogy between what he
thought was the latest cutting-edge
approach to understanding development
and that dispute in the late 17th and
18th centuries
he gets I've cut out various bits where
he gets all of the intellectual history
horribly wrong which is what you'd
expect from a developmental biologist
writing about the 17th century science
but the general sentiment is is quite
one I'm very much in agreement with so
what he's doing is he's drawing an
analogy between the preformation theory
the one that's often at least parody
does the idea that embryos were all
created by God at the beginning of time
packed down inside one another like
Russian dolls and the approach which in
1950s was sometimes referred to as
beanbag genetics and he's trying to say
that that's wrong that genetics modern
genetics isn't a vindication of the
preformation theory and instead that
there is some kind of original genesis
some new making epigenesis in the
development of the organism okay so why
do we keep going back to a late 17th
century dispute when and this this
really is a typical example whenever we
have deep theoretical discussions of the
nature of development in biology
somebody will label one or other person
in that discussion a preformation a--
store will alternatively say you know
surprisingly my ideas have indicate what
you might think was that crazy idea of
pre formation ism okay so why is that
well the answer is that there's a really
deep and differ
problem at the heart of all this so what
I want to do in this talk is explain
very very briefly that pre formation ISM
was a an intellectually substantial
response to a genuinely very difficult
scientific problem then I'm going to
talk about why we tend to think that
problem has gone away namely that we now
think about development using ideas from
the informational sciences and I'm going
to suggest that that solution what's
normally thought of is there couldn't
really be a problem anymore is less
satisfactory that we normally suppose
I'm going to introduce a new idea which
I call Crick information and suggests
that this offers some new ways forward
of thinking about that problem and I
guess sort of running through the talk
would be a general prejudice that the
epigenesis were right and that people in
contemporary biology and philosophy of
biology who say sympathetic things about
preformation ism are kind of on the
wrong side okay
so wide-ranging um know why that's done
common sentiment in the late 17th and
18th centuries okay if the egg consists
of homogeneous matter as is presumed by
this hypothesis then it can only develop
into a fetus by a miracle which would
surpass every other phenomena in the
world okay very common sentiment
philosophers tend to know only the very
late expression of and very subtly
nuanced and complex expression of that
criticism found in can't so most people
are familiar with this famous quote from
Kent's critique of judgment where
famously sometimes it's paraphrased in
various ways as their it's often as they
will never come the Newton of a blade of
grass okay so in fact it's it's a late
complex version of an argument that's
been put repeatedly from the I guess
1617 1680s
okay and what I want to get at is well
why why was that I what what what was
the foundation of this view that it's
just crazy to suppose that we can come
up with a mechanistic account of how
simple man
- organizes itself into a living being
the underlying arguments really simple
you find in lots of authors but here's I
think a very nice version of it from the
sky Charbonnet is the the biologist who
discovered parthenogenesis the ability
of some animals to produce live
offspring from unfertilized eggs so
quite it's I'll just read it out because
it's I think the best and the most
thorough presentation of the argument I
know so he's all force he's thinking of
new tenant Newtonian forces he's
thinking of gravity electricity
magnetism okay all force is
indeterminate and cannot of itself
produce specific effects in other words
it presupposes the existence of a
mechanism which it activates if
therefore there is nothing preformed in
the matter which the essential forces to
organize how can that force produce let
us say an animal instead of a plant a
particular kind of animal and a special
organ appropriate to that animal so the
idea is we've got a model of scientific
explanation in terms of attractive and
repulsive forces and what we're trying
to explain is how a simple system can
become more complex not just a more
complex in the sense of becoming
differentiated so that its parts are
more different from one another than
they were at the beginning and the
thought is the uniform application of
Newtonian forces can't make a
homogeneous system become in a
systematic way less homogeneous okay you
can't apply gravity to a drug a glass of
water and have it turn into a water
shaped sculpture of a swan or something
right it's just not the right kind of
explanation to explain that you'll find
this in the early 18th century French
writer Rene wrote Durham or criticizing
Pierre de Mer Pertwee the early French
Newtonian again saying you can't if the
little particles that we suppose are
going to make up the embryo are
attracted and repulsed by Newtonian
forces that might explain why they form
two lumps but it's not going to explain
how they form into beating hearts
systems of vessels right attractive and
repulsive forces between simple
particles just aren't going to cut it to
explain the emergence of organized
complexity so in my view the pre
formation estroux onto a winner with
this argument it's a very powerful
argument it lasts for a long time
terr dachuan the originator of the cell
theory of the organism in the 1830s and
here's chuan later in life making
exactly the same argument okay can't
conceive of a simple force that would
change its mode of action in order to
realize an idea and as historians like
Tim let Tim Lenoir have argued this
passage is very strongly influenced by
reading counts third critique right so a
simple force that will change its mode
of action order to realize an idea
without however possessing the
characteristic attributes of intelligent
beings I have preferred to seek in the
creator rather than the created the
cause of the finality to which the whole
of nature evidently bears witness so
again this very simple idea if it's the
case that the egg contains relatively
simple homogeneous matter then any force
which could shape that into a complex
organized being would be something like
a vital force and intellect he something
not within the accepted principles of
explanation in the physical sciences
it's the idea ok so deep an important
argument now people worried very clever
people worried about this for about a
century and a half and we don't worry
about it anymore why don't we worry
about it anymore we don't worry about it
I would argue because every educated
person has a half-baked version of a
solution and they think that somebody
who's an expert in biology can fill in
the details of this half-baked version
that they vaguely remember and if you
want a half-baked version go to a
journalist so this is an editorial in
the Economist magazine so high-class
journalism and it tells us an organism's
physiology and behavior dictate lee
large bytes genes and those genes are
merely repositories of information
written
in a surprisingly similar manner to the
one that computer scientists have
devised for the storage and transmission
of other information okay and now I get
to hold up a CD of the human genome and
tell you that you know the this is the
plan for building a human being so this
is this is you know if Gustav flow there
were adding an entry on the genome to
the dictionary of received ideas it
would say you know comment on how it's
like a computer program express
amazement that so much information can
be packed into such a simple thing right
okay all right so what I want to try and
argue now is that while there are all
sorts of applications of the
informational sciences to understanding
organize growth the impression that most
people outside the biological sciences
have and the impression that's often
given by extremely well-informed
biologists when they're asked to give a
popular talk on the subject that there
is some well worked out body of
biological theory which explains how
some kind of program in some sense
encoded in the nucleic acid molecules in
the nucleus of the cell explains through
in an informational mode how you're able
to get from that fertilized egg to the
life cycle of a fully functioning
organism but that's not I know to try
and persuade you that that's simply not
true there is no such solid organized
body of theory okay why do you suppose
there is one of the big problems with
this is a fairly simple ambiguity you in
what happens when people talk about the
genetic code so of course there's a
genetic code you can look it up in any
textbook it's straightforward on the
other hand some very large proportion of
talk about something in the genome
coding for something else isn't using
the genetic code in its formal sense
okay
so that's a genetic code nice and simple
if we insist on sticking strictly to
what the genetic code means
when you look it up in molecular biology
of the cell or any other decent source
then treated thinking the way as a
philosopher might well think of this as
a formal language logical language it's
a language with incredibly limited
expressive power it's a language which
allows you to talk about amino acids and
it allows you to talk using it allows
you to talk about linear order so all
you can say in the genetic code is which
amino acid should come next next to
which other amino acids and that's a
function of so the idea that you could
say other things in the genetic code is
like saying I'm only going to use
expressions for digitized latitude and
longitude but I'm going to write
literature why can't you write
literature using only expressions for
digitized latitude and longitude because
just restricting the expressive power of
the language you're using to being able
to say a very very small number of
things you can't talk about anything
other than identifying locations using
that system okay
so there's a really deep it's not like
if you tried really hard you would be
able to express other sentences using
digital latitude and longitude okay it's
a insoluble problem in the same way you
can't use the genetic code in the formal
sense to say anything other than
something about the order of linear
order of elements in a polypeptide
that's it and importantly of course
there's nothing wrong with the other way
of talking about coding it's perfectly
good English but as Peter Godfrey Smith
is one of my favorite arguments often
known as the pizza argument Peters
argued that the error of thinking that
genes code so that those there are there
that the genetic code extends beyond
that is similar to thinking that because
President Nixon's order to go and burgle
the Watergate Center led to his
impeachment he ordered his own
impeachment okay
the semantics semantics locutions don't
run down the whole chain of causation
okay so if I another example I stole
from Peter because you just came up with
a list of them they're great suppose I
order an extra
Pizza it comes late therefore my partner
is upset and we have a quarrel I didn't
order a quarrel okay okay I caused a
quarrel but you can't take if you have a
chain of causation one step of which has
a semantic relationship between the
cause and the effect it doesn't convert
every downstream step in the causal
chain into a semantic relationship okay
so that's the error that's made by
saying well genes code for proteins and
of course they code for phenotypes
therefore problem solved okay it really
is as simple as that okay so it's not
the genetic code sensors trick - what
about other theories of information well
if you you pull the literature download
the literature doers of a MEDLINE search
or something on theories of biological
information you'll discover a rich and
varied landscape in the 80s there was an
extensive effort by a number of
biologists mainly some philosophers to
unify thermodynamics and evolution via
the common currencies of information and
entropy I'm not going to talk much about
that I think I'm just going to make an
argument by Authority look at the
literature it's think pretty much
universally accepted that nothing of any
intellectual consequence was produced by
this endeavor the new much more I think
interesting and again long large body of
work to create a science of biosemiotics
now there's a new wave of biosemiotics
coming out at the moment mainly around
this guy gunther vitani which seems to
be much more sort of detailed the
oriented towards the science but you
know this again the stuff from the 90s
I'm citing there I mean the project of
thinking that we can represent what
happens in cells using something like a
person approach to meaning just it
hasn't generated substantial scientific
results right there aren't new
discoveries about what cells do that
come out of that okay I would argue that
the whole idea of saying that we we
start with
symbolic systems of communication and
then go back into cells with analogical
reasoning is probably a bad strategy but
lots of people wouldn't agree with that
okay
um they're just an example very
impressive example of course there are
lots of detailed examples of applying
work from applying formalism from the
information Sciences specific biological
problems so this sliders theory of
molecular machines which is I think a
lovely bit of work basically says we're
going to so enzymes are highly specific
to their substrates at least that's one
central application why don't we think
about that as the enzyme having to
decide where to bind so we have a
possibility space of things it could
bind to it's got to make a certain
number of binary decisions in order to
uniquely identify what substrate it's
going to bind to and then we can you
know interesting results about in that
sense how given how much information it
would take to uniquely bind to a
particular site how complex with a
molecule have to be before it can do
that and there's lots of interesting
work like that that is doesn't okay why
doesn't that interestingly one of the
interesting things about that specific
example is that it's specifically one of
the relationships in biology it doesn't
apply to is the relationship between DNA
and protein formalized in the genetic
code because that's not a stereo
chemical relationship okay it's got this
arbitrary factor introduced by transfer
RNAs so rather interesting is a really
impressive example of thinking about
biological information applies to a lot
of things one of the things that doesn't
apply to is genes coding for proteins
okay which means it's not going to turn
into a general theory of the kind that
we're sort of looking for you lots of
other examples of you know good good
formal work which doesn't have the
potential to generalize like that quite
a lot of people in the current for the
software literature would take the view
that what we really have when the the
what we actually have in the application
of information language in biology is a
series of overlapping but not the
tightly related exercises in model
building using analogical reasoning
where the source domain for the analogy
are various different bits of human
communication formal information
Sciences so on and so forth okay so
we've just we've got several different
source domains for a metaphor and we're
using them to do analogical model
building sometimes in in a way that
leads to big rigorous develop models
sometimes in a way that just operates at
the level of useful analogies and
metaphors
so it's a very deflation review of
what's going on in some recent writing
okay so distinction which I and others
have drawn in many places just to get on
the table a distinction between senses
of information in which information is
fundamentally way of talking about
correlation and senses of information
which are related to the philosophers
obsession with intentionality with
meaning okay um so as famous philosopher
HP Grice this idea of natural meaning
smoke smoke means fire the number of
rings in a tree means the age of the
tree the concentration of trapped gases
in ice cores means something about past
climate okay
perfectly good sense of meaning but very
minimal and of course Shannon's
quantitative measure of information
which once again is strictly reducible
to some kind of pattern of correlation a
lot of the time when people in
philosophy talk about information
they're really only talking about
information which rises to the level of
the semantic and again something
philosophers find very facile easy I
often find non philosophers find a very
strange way of thinking about this
semantic information is essentially
normative it's essentially normative in
the sense that if an object has semantic
content then there are normative
conditions applying to it if it's
indicative then their truth conditions
it's got its normatively required to be
produced
this situation so what do I have to put
that in simplest possible terms if I say
that
unicorns are bad-tempered then that's an
utterance which is failing in a world in
which there are no bad temper or in
which unicorns aren't bad-tempered okay
something's gone wrong if I come out
here and set unicorns about tempered
things go well if they're a bad tempered
unicorns things go badly for my
utterance in the real world where there
are no bad tempered you know unicorns
and if there were there wouldn't be bad
tempered okay and imperative statements
have compliance conditions if I come in
here and say you should all put money
into my Swiss bank account things go
well if you put money into my Swiss bank
account they go badly for that utterance
if you all just giggle okay the
utterance has not achieved its goal so
you have normative either truth
conditions or compliance conditions or
for all the other classes of utterances
other success conditions all right and
that's what we're looking for in the
sense of meaning that we find in thought
and in human human language okay so
surprisingly a lot of the more thorough
rigorous work in recent philosopher
biology has concentrated on showing that
biological information is genuinely
semantic in this sense that it has
normative truth conditions or normative
compliance conditions which is I think
you one should find surprising coming
the field from the outside since the
kind of it set the whole family of
sensitive information under my first dot
point there look as if they're
unproblematically part of the natural
world and the senses of information
under my second dot point are those that
cause so much problems in contemporary
philosophy wondering about the place of
the mind in nature okay so they're a
funny place to look for a biological
notion of information nevertheless
that's where people have gone including
the eminent late evolutionary biologist
John Maynard Smith so here's Maynard
Smith with so he's first of all just
giving a kind of gryce's natural meaning
definition of information says with this
definition there's no difficulty in
saying a gene carries him
Meishan bah bah blah individual with the
gene for achondroplasia will have short
arms and legs but we legally say that a
baby's environment carries in for this
we were just talking about causal
correlations then he says informational
language has been used to characterize
genetic causes I will justify this the
distinction could be justified only if
the concept of information is used in
biology for causes that have the
property of intentionality which ought
to be a very surprising sentence to read
from an eminent scientist a DNA molecule
has a particular sequence because it
specifies a particular protein but a
cloud is not black because it predicts
rain this element of intentionality
comes from natural selection okay in
fact I was at a it's interesting this is
I think an example of sort of deep
intellectual honesty I was at a
conference in 1996 where John Maynard
Smith was giving a keynote address in
which he said people are complaining
about not having a clear definition of
information well we mean it roughly in
the sense of information theory and then
he started to think about it and write
about it and four years later you've got
him coming along and saying well it's
not that's not going to work we're gonna
have to find some kind of basis for
intentionality in nature in order to get
the notion of biological information to
do what we want lots of philosophers
have tried to give Maynard Smith what he
wanted I think perhaps the best
practitioner at the moment Nick Lachey
at King's College London and they've
drawn on the work of great connecticut
philosopher Ruth Milliken at University
of Connecticut so probably the most
popular approach in contemporary
philosophy is to use Millican so-called
Helio semantics or evolutionary
semantics so the idea is to derive the
intentionality of genetic information
from evolutionary design how can you
have normative how can genes have
normative properties they can have
normative properties because they were
designed by evolution to do something
and they can either succeed in doing it
or fail to do it okay we try to get
normativity out of natural selection and
then apply that to genes
I'm not going to talk much about this
the little figure on the right is Nick
Shay's way of thinking about this it's
roughly that there are a whole bunch of
correlations between which genes you
have in which phenotypes you have and
after a certain episode of number of
episodes of natural selection have
occurred we can start to say that when
one of those genotypes leads to a
particular phenotype it's doing what
natural selection designed it to do
because that particular relationship has
survived these episodes and is found
more commonly in nature than it was
before it's a very simple idea working
it out in detail as more effort and in
this sort of genetic Teela semantics so
we say that we want to ascribe
indicative semantic content to a DNA
sequence by saying under what conditions
did natural selection intend organisms
to have that DNA sequence okay so we say
that a mutation conferring resistance to
some disease has the cement intentional
semantic content you should be resistant
to that disease if it was desire if
there is a natural Selective episode
which caused the possession of that DNA
sequence to occur in environments where
that disease is prevalent okay and we do
the same for we can also ascribe
imperative content if the reason that a
particular genetic variation survived
was that it led to a particular
phenotype then we say that that's what
it's meant or it's meant to do is to
make you have that phenotype
now I regard this when it's done really
rigorously in the way Nick Shea does it
as a perfectly reasonable exercise in
analogical reasoning and if you can
build evolutionary models that produce
interesting consequences by treating the
system as if it's designing signals or
designing pieces of DNA to inform the
organism about the environment which
will find itself you know you can do
whatever i mean the the currency of
evaluation for analogical reasoning in
biology is producing productive models
that's it it's not realism okay it's not
you don't stamp your foot about is it
really
does it really have imperative content
now it was a matter of fact many of the
people is literature tend to stamp their
foot about that and say it's just true
it has meaning has you know whatever
I think that's misguided for quite
general reasons in philosophy of science
I think the only reasonable currency for
assessing a statement like the parent is
signaling to the offspring is when we
use that analogy do we end up with a
model that illuminates the aspect of
biology we're trying to think about I
can't see any other reasonable currency
and I'm not interested in somebody
saying well you're stretching the
meaning of above oblong I mean that's
not interesting as criticism okay on the
other hand I think there's a fundamental
objection to this whole approach having
anything to say about the problem we
started with it's much easier to see
when we deal with non-genetic signals
between one organism and another so I
think Tilia semantics is fine if you
want to build evolutionary models you
want to think about the evolution of
heredity systems and build models for
that but it isn't any good at explaining
how the presence of certain factors in
development lead to the growth of the
organism so the pictures on the right
are a famous case in parental effects
research let me just tell you the story
the little guy at the top is the seed
beetle startling Bartus it can lay its
eggs typically lays its eggs on one of
two plants thing called the blue palo
verde and a thing called a cat chloric
Asya that's me trying the bottom one is
I tried to take a photo of something
that scratched me in the Mojave Desert
which I thought and best of my knowledge
was probably a catclaw acacia so I'm
relying on my own very very bad
botanical identification skills for that
one the the other one is obviously
nicked off the internet so the challenge
posed to the developing offspring is
very different on these two kinds of
seeds one of them requires the offspring
to grow very fast and achieve a larger
adult size in order to have a decent
probability of survival okay so your
little mother seed beetle detects
whether it's on
one of these seeds or the other if it's
on the more demanding plant it raised
lays a small number of large eggs which
grow very quickly and become big robust
beetles that can deal with the
challenges of that seed if it's growing
on the other plant it grows a lot it
plays lots and lots of very small eggs
okay and these of course are nicely
adaptively balanced strategies for
dealing with the two seeds now I think
you can build that I know you can build
a great model of that by thinking that
what we're looking at here is the mother
acquiring information about its
environment and passing it on to its
offspring so the mother acquires
information about what seed its
offspring have to live on and it passes
that information to the offspring and we
can model that we can think in terms of
for example of you know what sort what
what are the when would using that kind
of signal evolve
what kind of patchiness of the
environment would we have to have and
yeah that's a perfectly developed field
of biological modeling okay but listen
to the following explanation I say I
want as a developmental biologist I've
got a fertilized startling Bartis egg
and I want to understand how why it is
that that particular egg has a higher
growth rate and a greater adult size and
somebody says not a problem it's because
the the protein the content of the egg
sends a signal to the mechanisms of
development to grow fast and achieve a
larger adult size okay now my view is
that if you're a developmental biologist
that is right up there with opium
putting you to sleep because it has a
dormitory virtue okay I mean the the
amount of food in the egg does indeed
cause that but it doesn't cause it by
giving the instruction to grow fast to
the mechanisms of development that's
getting you that sort of ground zero in
terms of actually giving any kind of
explanation of what goes on okay what
instead we want to know for example is
what is the different gene expression
pattern in the next stage of that the
early stages of that egg at what point
does the
or does it just you know get more food
why does that increase the growth rate
not just the final size okay what's
happening basically well let you
understand what's happened to gene
expression you've got nowhere with
explaining what happened okay so it
seems to me it's kind of obvious when
we're talking about something like the
amount of nutrition in the egg that it's
fine to describe it as a signal but
that's not the kind of description which
converts into a causal explanation of
how you get from a fertilized egg to an
adult organism
okay it's not mechanistic in the right
sense I think we overlook that whenever
we're talking about DNA sequences
because there are so many other notions
of information floating around whenever
you think about so when somebody in what
we've read you got is so that the the
scheme I showed you earlier from Nick
Shea applies perfectly to this case okay
so according to genetic teeler semantics
the egg mass has the indicative semantic
content you are growing on this plant
and it has the imperative semantic
content you should grow fast and achieve
a large adults eyes okay
the point I'm trying to make is that
when we talk about a genetic signal from
parent to offspring
it doesn't immediately stare you in the
face that that explanation of
development is vacuous and I would argue
that's because you've got two ideas of
information in mind one is the one
that's actually licensed by genetic
t-there semantics and the other is some
other notion of information which
information is actually imminent it's
there physically in the thing it's
making stuff happen okay little
knockdown argument as to why genetic
Tito semantics can't do anything
interesting developmental biology the
whole approach depends on saying that
your information content depends on your
phylogenetic history so if you have to
physically identical eggs one of which
did not does not have its physical
structure as a result of a particular
process of adaptive evolution it has
completely different in
Meishan content in that sense of
information okay so two things are
physically identical one has the
information one doesn't the information
can't be relevant to explaining the
causal powers of that physical system
how it will develop in future as a
result of its structure okay you can
yeah so it's a historic okay if this
information this sense is a historical
property and historical properties are
causally inert okay so that's why I
think this is all lots of fun thinking
about evolution but absolutely useless
for thinking about development so back
to basics so what I wouldn't want to do
now in the last part of the talk is to
outline to you a strategy that Carolla
starts and I have come up with for
thinking about these issues a very
boring notion of information that we've
decided to try and sell you as less
boring than initially looks and I think
we can make some real progress on
vindicating the I am for make the idea
that some notion of biological
information gets at that problem that
the preformation ax stand the epigenesis
we're talking about using this idea and
on the way we can do a certain amount of
indication of epigenesis so what I'm
going to talk about for the rest of the
talk is an idea I call quick information
and I call it that because it's we're
trying to give a philosophical
explication sort of development of the
meaning stipulative meaning of the word
information in Crick's famous 1958 paper
on protein synthesis okay and that's the
definition information here means the
precise determination of sequence either
of bases in the nucleic acid or amino
acid residues in the protein i want to
going to try and show you is that
analyzing that definition using a
container fashionable contemporary
account of causation in philosophy of
science shows that it's actually more
generally applicable it's not just about
what genes do it's actually a quite
interesting sense of information more
generally and that it's got some nice
properties okay so we need to introduce
so there's going to be one slide here
which will bore and irritate all the
biologists in the room followed by one
that will bore
rotate all the philosophers in the room
so that's fair so first of all the sort
of trivial biological trivialities two
ideas of biological specificity so the
idea of biological specificity comes in
the late nineteenth century it's the
idea that organisms have incredibly
fine-grained control of their chemistry
okay they're able to so you have the
capacity to recognize exactly one kind
of infectious particle you have the
capacity to to metabolize exactly one
very specific biochemical reaction and
to do so very very energetically
efficiently and so forth that leads in
the interwar years to the sort of modern
standard idea of stereochemical or
conformational specificity the classic
example is a relationship between ends
enzymes and the things to which they
bind and what we I mean the now this has
all got infinitely more complicated in
the last few years and it's all turning
into a quantum theory and so on and so
I'm not going to go there but
classically you think about this as a
three-dimensional lock-and-key
relationship between two molecules okay
the three-dimensional shape of the
molecules affects their capacity to form
weak bonds with one another
alright so you've got incredibly
sensitive interactions going on because
you have very complicated shapes and
those very complicated shapes allow
organisms to exercise this very very
fine grain control over their chemistry
okay so that's conformational
specificity or stereochemical
specificity my historical colleagues
seem to have a pretty strong consensus
that something very new happened when
Crick introduced the idea that we refer
to as informational specificity the idea
that the specificity in a Cell can be
encoded in the linear sequence of a
nucleic acid so again very
rough-and-ready kind of bit of history
one reason for skepticism about where
their DNA could be the genetic material
was that DNA is boring and repetitive it
just doesn't have enough structure to do
the job of via stereochemical
city if you're going to make all of the
molecules in the cell by 3d templating
of nucleic acids there just isn't enough
structure in nucleic acid to do the job
okay it's boring and repetitive proteins
have complex rich interesting structures
nucleic acids have boring repetitive
structures so there's an inclination to
think that it's all the proteins in the
chromosome that must be the bit that's
doing the work because they're the only
plausible source of 3d stereochemical
specificity Crick's move is to say
there's another way of getting
specificity and that's just the
combinatorics of a few simple elements a
linear order of elements an indefinite
number of ways of combining those simple
elements and we can get our specificity
that way out of linear order okay and
that's embodied in these two incredibly
famous fifty-eight ideas of Crick the
sequence hypothesis in its simplest form
it assumes that this is quote so the
whole next bit is a quote from Crick
okay in its simplest form assumes the
specificity of a piece of nucleic acid
is expressed solely by the sequence of
its bases and this sequence is a simple
code for the amino acid sequence of a
particular protein and then phrase you
hear bandied about a bit more the
central dogma this states that once
information has passed into a protein it
cannot get out again the quotation marks
around information scare quotes in more
detail the transfer of information from
nucleic acids the protein may be
possible but blah blah blah and then bit
I quoted earlier we've got put it in
scare quotes because we're stipulating
right and then we say what are we
stipulate in information means here the
precise determination of sequence either
of bases in the nucleic acid or of amino
acid residues in the protein okay so
this idea obviously turned into a
central Orthodox part of contemporary
molecular biology it also inspired a lot
of attempts to think information lis
about the genetic code but it didn't
lead to taking that stipulative
definition of information seriously okay
the measures that get applied to the two
genes and genetic codes after that are
all standard Shannon
of mutual information they're not that
sense of information that just gets sort
of taken as you know sensible thing to
say but it's not a technical new
definition of information that needs to
be developed which is kind of what I'm
suggesting okay so that's the biological
trivia now the philosophical trivia a
very currently fashionable approach to
causation due to the Pittsburgh
philosopher Jim Woodward is to argue
that causal relationships are a
privileged subset of the statistical
relationships between a set of variables
in some scientific representation of the
world so we represent we're not a
scientific model we represent as a
directed graph where all the variables
are related and then we pick out a
privileged subset of the edges in that
graph which ones they're the ones which
would provide the basis upon which one
variable could be used to manipulate the
value of the other that's the idea right
very straightforward I mean Woodward
claims to be just kind of I guess
cashing out part of scientific practice
meant to be a partly descriptive of
scientific practice um a lot of
conditions here what it means to for
something to be directly manipulated
rather than indirectly and so forth and
some very it's a very very weak sense of
causation you're allowed to talk about
causation in this approach
even when incredibly specific boundary
conditions are required for the relevant
relationship to hold between your two
variables so even when it's only in some
insanely careful experimental set up
that you've got that there is any
relationship between the two variables
under those conditions you can talk
about causation so I'm not going to go
into that in details it's become the
substance big philosophical literature
it's as I say currently fashionable
approach and I think a very practical
approach of way of thinking about why we
bother to talk about causes when we're
doing science
roughly okay more interesting is
Woodward's attempt to strengthen the
notion of causation so you can think of
the basic approach as saying look
the whole gamut of a context in which it
would be permissible to identify a
relationship as causal but it's going to
include lots of very weak uninteresting
causal relationships so when we get into
a lot of the time when people
so again Woodward's got some quite nice
stuff on this when there are scientific
disputes about which relationships are
causal he'd rather interpret them as
which causal relationships are
significant worth talking about whatever
okay so it's kind of graded notion and
one important dimension of what makes a
causal relationship and important causal
relationship is this idea of causal
specificity a lot of earlier work on
this in other philosophers David Lewis
for example wrote about this so Woodward
has tried to develop the idea of a court
of a specific cause to requirements I
mean one this idea of proportionality
so proportional what's what's an example
of a causal relationship that isn't
proportional well if I said for example
I've got a gene which affects eye color
and I say how does it act well its
embryonic lethal right organism dies
when it's only a little ball of cells so
definitely gets rid of the doesn't have
red eyes anymore okay that looks like a
really bad explanation it's a bad
explanation because I've the the grain
of analysis of my cause isn't fitting
the grain of analysis of my effect okay
what we want is some genetic variation
which is changing the thing we're
interested in not changing a much larger
event of which that's a tiny part okay
so that's proportionality and then this
idea of fine-grain influence the idea
that it's not just that there's this one
vac so think about the difference
between a well this is what you wanted
Woodward's examples which works quite
nicely there's all the difference in the
world I say to you I want you to change
the channel on the TV okay well one
thing you could do is to switch the TV
off the other thing you could do is to
tune the TV to a different channel okay
it's used to make more sense in the days
of analog TVs I should come up with it
but you're all honey you've got some of
your that yard
okay good yeah or even a radio we used
to have to turn knobs okay again it
looks as if there's something it more
interesting about the causal
relationship where it's not just that
there's a relationship between one value
of the the cause and the effect but
rather there's a range of one variable
that smoothly maps into a range in the
other variable that's a particularly
interesting kind of causal relationship
so the idea of specificity you know it
needs more work I'm not convinced that
it needs more philosophical work I think
there are a lot of ideas that the idea
that you can make an idea precise by
chopping more conceptual distinctions is
often a mistake you get to a certain
point and at that point the only way to
make the idea really precise is to
operationalize it to stick it into some
specific context of use where you're
performing experimental operations of
some kind of come up with measures and
the idea you can find to you in an idea
with just more conceptual distinctions I
think just runs out a certain point
where the philosophers should hand over
right and I try you know while I think
there are issues around woulda's notion
of specificity I don't think the way to
solve them is by writing more philosophy
papers with counter examples the way to
solve them is by showing that the idea
can be put to work and hopefully that
something more concrete will will emerge
when you do that now I think that you
can make a good argument that Crick the
what Crick's talking about when he
starts talking about information is
inspired by many of the same thoughts
that underlie this idea of causal
specificity so I'm emphasizing another
quote from the paper says the central
dogma deals with the detailed residue by
residue transfer of sequential
information I think is reflecting that
idea of fine grain control okay it's not
just that you can switch off whether the
gene is on or off rather it's you can
alter the sequence in any combination
will give you some and you can you get a
you know the closer the sequence is of
course we're ignoring frame shifts yeah
I'm just right you know assuming we got
a frame the closer the sequence is the
the closer the the proteins will be okay
similar sequences produce similar
protein eyes
performs that kind of idea okay so let's
at what I think is going on in cricket
so what is quick information we use the
phrase quick information talk about
specific difference making with respect
to the linear structure of a gene
product and not just proteins any gene
product okay
so we said core if a cause makes the
specific difference to the structure of
a molecule
it contains quick information for that
molecule and the paradigm example is
coding sequence of DNA and an RNA or a
protein okay why call that information
well there I think we have a very
structured approach to why we're allowed
to call it information it's Carnap 1950
it's when when are you allowed to
introduce expecations in science alright
so first of all I would argue and would
words also argued in a slightly
different context that this idea is
getting at why it is that biologists are
sometimes drawn to use informational
language so when Scott Gilbert
distinguishes between an instructive
cause and a permissive cause or a
permissive cause is something like the
stuff you need to keep the organism
alive or to have any kind of you know
differentiation going on at all okay so
just starve it of you know a basic
chemical building block that's going to
be a permissive cause I think that's
what they're getting at this similar
idea of causal specificity and secondly
I'm going to defend it just in terms of
if it's useful to use information to
mean this in order to develop an
understanding of the sources of order in
living systems then it's a suitable
explication for that project
okay so again not interested in you know
the classic kind of philosophical
counter example you know on your
definition if we all lived on a planet
with only three chemical elements and
where evolution wasn't true and then you
tell some story and say doesn't sound
right to call that information well
maybe I'm not interested right that's
not the game here okay we've got you
have to forex but I mean explicate
efficient continuity with why you
started talking about this idea in the
first place and you've got to show that
your stipulative changes to it are
useful given what you're trying to
achieve and that's that's all I need to
do
okay so if you want don't like
information we'll call it information
all right there we go okay now here's a
quote from another very influential
paper in 1958 it's a paper and it's what
I find really fascinating about this is
the insight it's like the fact that
Crick's 58 paper has a reference to
MacFarlane Burnet doesn't agree with
this I mean there's so much must have
been so much discussion going on in the
years leading up to these papers we've
been you know which again would be
fascinating to do the art and some of
it's been done the archival research on
that but this is a paper in 58 by David
nany well-known ciliate biologist and
it's the paper that introduces the word
epigenetic in the modern sense where you
pick up your time magazine the new
science of epigenetics okay introduces
the word epigenetic in that sense into
biology and he's talking about the ideas
we've just talked about quick sequence
hypothesis and central dogma although
he's talking about them in some sense
before they're I think before they're
published certainly anyway so he says
this view of the nature of the genetic
material that's Crick's sequence
hypothesis permits a clearer conceptual
distinction than has previously been
possible between two types of cellular
control systems and this I love this bit
on the one idea the maintenance of a
library of specificities and I can't
think of a better description of the
coding sequences of the genome than a
library of specificities both expressed
and unexpressed is accomplished by a
template replicating mechanism on the
other hand auxilary mechanisms with
different principles of operation are
involved in determining which
specificities are to be expressed in any
particular cell to simplify the
discussion of these two types of systems
they will be referred to as genetic
systems and epigenetic systems the term
epigenetic is chosen to emphasize the
reliance of these systems on the genetic
systems and to underscore their
significance in developmental processes
okay so that's where epigenetics in the
modern sense comes from if the science
had stayed the way it was in 1958 then
Crick information would be found in
coding sequences and epigenetic
mechanisms would do exactly what nanny
describes they would take down a library
from the shelf a volume from the shelf
the library and express the relevant
gene product from it but the information
specifying the gene product would be in
the volume and the controller
architecture of control engineering
would be about pulling volumes off the
shelf saying which one is to be read at
which time and place in the developing
organism but we'll be glad to know the
science has moved on since 1958 so what
I want to argue the next is just a quote
from a recent paper on this kind of
stuff what I want to argue the next few
slides is that Crick information is
distributed between genetic and
epigenetic mechanisms okay so the first
idea what introduces what what Crowell
and I call genetic under determination
and amplification so quote there is
increasing awareness multiple often
overlapping mechanisms exist for
amplifying the repertoire of protein
products specified through the mammalian
genome expanding array of processing and
targeting mechanisms each representing
potentially important restriction point
in the regulation of eukaryotic gene
expression expanding the possibilities
specified by the literal code of the
Drina so what that's getting at is the
idea that the transcriptome the total
class of gene products you can make is a
couple of orders of magnitude bigger
than the number of genes that you've got
to make them from where genes is being
read as a structural unit in that
position okay now in that case you're
getting several different often actually
radically different gene products out of
a single underlying sequence now the
specced now I should say something not
going to talk about this at all I'm for
the purposes of this talk and in fact
all the stuff I'm doing at the moment
I'm living in a kind of fantasy crick
world in which there is no protein
folding problem because I have no idea
how to extend the stuff I'm saying to
take that on ok so I'm just going to
pretend that we've explained biological
specificity when we've explained the
primary structure of products ok and
then you know one day maybe I'll know
how to think about the rest of that so
that's yeah all right so under that in
that crazy simplified view of the world
what we've discovered
from the kinds of facts being referred
to here is that when we take a
particular gene product the specificity
which is embodied in that product is
under specified by the coding sequence
from which it was transcribed so then
the question is where's the rest of the
Crick information to specify the
particular gene product where is it
coming from um so just to remind people
again who don't not familiar with this
one source of this is alternative
splicing so if you think of a gene as
there's probably a summer on here
there's probably a pointer it doesn't
really need a pointer does it is that a
pointer there we go that's a pointer
great if you think of a coding sequence
as consisting of a series on this is
this is a whole bunch of reification
going on here for the philosopher in the
room right if you sort of if you treat a
DNA sequence as if it considered coding
sequence if it consists of a chunk of
things called exons separated by things
called introns then there are all sorts
of interesting ways once you've
transcribed that sequence into RNA of
cutting and pasting it together to make
different things okay so here's what
you've got in the DNA if you just look
at it straight for this is the classical
kind of model it's going to look like
that but you could leave one out you
could treat one of the introns as an
exon why not you could do it in two
different ways you could actually change
your mind about where the exon intron
boundaries are you could introduce a
different splice site you can also I
mean actually gets more complicated you
can turn them around put them in
backwards
you can make you know multiple copies of
the thing and then put one you can put
one together that's got you know exon
one two two three four
if you want it you can do all sorts of
stuff okay so that's changing what you
get and that's being supported by a
complex modular structure of sites at
which you can bind factors that are
going to cause it to be spliced in one
way or the other and the other thing on
it is just in case you don't know is the
fact
and you say not really time to kind of
talk about this properly but the other
thing you can do is just to rewrite the
thing
okay so MRA editing it's just an example
of one form you get in humans you just
take the messenger RNA and you bring in
a bunch of machinery that rewrites what
the RNA bases are okay so you literally
edit it okay in the most straightforward
sense okay so the result is you're
getting lots and lots of Sep okay you've
got you're getting lots and lots of
things out of the same coding sequence
how is that happening well two ideas two
buzzwords that I've stolen from these
guys regulated recruitment and
combinatorial control so what's that
mean we're assembling very large
complexes of multiple molecules at one
of these sites in order to determine
what will happen to that messenger RNA
and we're doing that in a way that's
regulated by the metabolism of the cell
so we're very specifically bringing many
factors together and attaching them to
the DNA or to the RNA you know many many
many levels of process here which I'm
not going to talk about and the fact
that the both the underlying DNA
sequence has this modular structure and
the fact that you're bringing together
many factors that can be put together in
different combinations gives you
massively combinatorial control of that
process you can do it in many many
different ways
okay so regulated recruitment and
combinatorial control that's how you do
it and shots and I have argued that this
adds up to what we call distributed
causal specificity so when somebody says
what makes it what specifies that that
that molecule have exactly that
structure we want to say that the
specificity for the informational
specificity in quick sense the Crick
information for that molecule is
distributed between the coding sequence
from which the mRNA is transcribed and
this mass of other factors and the more
distal factors that are causing them to
be brought together in this particular
a combination at the time okay yeah okay
so that's that's the story now I want to
argue that this vindicates an epigenetic
view of molecular biology just to make
us you know got to make fun of the pre
formation is so we'll put this standard
picture for making fun of Reformation
ists which the pre formations didn't
actually say and it's it's a horrible
parody of their sophisticated views okay
couple of people Stephen Jay Gould and
more recently in at more length Peter
Godfrey Smith have argued that the pre
formation esteem uncle Asst but they
weren't wrong at the molecular level
because the structure of the molecular
components is preformed in the DNA okay
so the material I had in the last two
slides for me is a shows that that's
actually not true in fact there are
multiple factors
none of which contain a full
representation of the molecule are
brought together in processes regulated
by the larger system of which they are
part now if that is an epigenesis I
don't know what it is I mean that's what
epigenesis was always all about it's the
larger system is bringing together
things in a way that lets you do
something which was not prefigured in
any one place okay and so we would say
that the susan armor the Crick
information manifest in a biomolecule is
produced by an ontogeny of information
so there's no one place in the cell
where that information is okay it's only
there in the whole system now just a
crediting effect dick baring was the
first person to use the phrase molecular
epigenesis but Carolla was the first one
to kind of argue that it was true so
there you go to different kinds of
origination um now moving on quickly I
just want to say one more theaters you
can add to this that makes the vision of
biological information even more
interesting so far I've been treating
the coding sequences in the genome as
surrounded by a regulatory architecture
which is itself in the genome and
perhaps in the cellular metabolism
around the genome you can actually push
that regulatory architecture out even
wider in a kind of systematic way and
that's yet another of the many meanings
of epigenetic which is when people talk
about I have tried to crawl and I have
tried to eschew talking about epigenetic
inheritance it's just too confusing
so epigenetic inheritance for me is
strictly the process involving heritable
heritable changes in gene expression
what a lot of people mean when they talk
about epigenetic inheritance we like to
call extra genetic inheritance you know
which is all the other kind of heredity
system so what sorts of things well
here's the kind of picture that you know
you'll find in a kind of you know
standard popular representation of what
genes do you know jeans make soma or
bodies and they make genes so these are
there's that's this the you know the
soma that's that's going to die its
mortal here's the immortal you know
genome going on and on making bodies
here's a kind of rival picture do to
actually do to tobias aller who's a
parental effects researcher which I
think actually is far closer to what
what you know what actually happens in
it what uncontroversially what actually
happens okay is it true that jeans make
jeans jeans make bodies and then bodies
die well no what's actually true is
something like this
you've got a zygote which contains both
genes and importantly a whole bunch of
gene products which are actually driving
almost all the activity in the cell for
the first few few stages few cycles then
you've got the parents doing a whole
bunch of stuff which is structuring the
environment of the zygote so what's this
about well that can be for example
laying you on a cat chloric a seer or it
can be breastfeeding or it can be
exposing you to the dominant values of a
particular linguistic community okay
it's all yeah so that's a very that's a
complicated box and that's a complicated
box all right and of course arguably you
might want to divide this these guys are
interested in drawing this diagram
because they're trying to do the
quantitative genetics of the of these
characters okay and to do the
quantitative genetics right if you don't
do this you just get the wrong
predictions okay that's what parental
effects researchers do okay so if you
buy into that
then you might be interested in one last
idea before I finish which pushed very
strongly by my collaborator Corolla sh
dots the idea of a developmental niche
and I don't have time to talk about the
example but this is a well-known
developmental psychologist I guess or
developmental apologist at University of
Indiana Meredith West who spent about 30
years showing that a bird whose behavior
had been said to be programmed in the
genes by Ernst Meier actually depends on
incredibly complicated processes of
social learning and ecological
ecological niche construction so it's a
cute little bird and since it never
meets its own parents being a parasite
it's raised by different species Maya
famously in his in one of his most
famous papers actually the paper where
he introduces the distinction between
proximate and ultimate causes said
here's an example of an animal whose
behaviour must be programmed in the
genome and then West spent the next 20
odd years showing that well actually the
male's learn their species specific song
by reinforcement from the females who
you know have heard it before and that
they they work out what species they are
by comparing what they look like with
the birds around them and looking for
the ones that look like them and there's
this wonderful program of showing that
how do you get a normal cowbird you get
a normal cow bird out of an incredibly
complicated structured environment and
if you don't have that very complicated
structured environment produced by the
activity of previous generations you
don't get a normal cowbird so for me
that is straightforwardly continuous
with the regulatory architecture of the
genome life as I said to a philosopher
called Jason Prince who's famous for
being us very very strong
environmentalist said to him Jessie
you've got to realize that you know
higher education is just a way of
regulating genome expression all right
all right life is a process of regulated
genome expression from birth to death
and that's why the old nature-nurture
dispute is really really silly and one
of the disputes that's worth arguing
about is the relative importance of
different layers of regulatory
architecture starting in the genome
self and extending way out to child care
and ecological environment okay that's a
real dispute with scientific content
nature versus nurture isn't okay so
conclusions
um I should take what's the connection
listen quick information that probably
isn't clear to you it seems so obvious
to me what I get very excited about is
the idea that to a first approximation
when you want to show rigorously that
this stuff is important what you need to
show is that it's contributing quick
information to specific molecules that's
the connection
that's goodness if you could show that
you'd have really given a rigorous
vindication of the claim that this is
continuous in some interesting sense
with what's going on with genome
architecture okay so conclusion Creek
information is a simple approach to
information nothing complicated about it
well there is if you try and quantify it
but we're hoping to do but it's a simple
approach allows us to explore the idea
that living systems differ from other
physical systems because they're
informed so another kind of just to
unpack that a little bit what do you
have to do in order to make an organism
well my claim is what you've got to do
is to create a system which is able to
produce the right to pull down the right
volume from the library of specificities
at the right time if you can do that
you're to a first approximation that's
what you need to do in order to make an
organism okay you need to get the
specificity expressed in your life cycle
to happen in another life cycle okay and
I think I've been giving you a very
brief sketch of how you do that unlike
many other senses of biological
information quick information is a
causal factor in the operation of living
systems how do I know that because I
defined it into what quick information
is okay great information is a specific
kind of causal dependence between
variables in a model that's what it is
it could be generalized to cover both
genetic and epigenetic mechanisms for
transmitting and expressing biological
specificity so it's a way to explore and
potentially to quantify what in earlier
publications I've called the parity of
genetic and other factors in development
the idea that there really are doing the
same thing in some theoretical
significant sense okay quick information
is a way to vindicate that okay thank
you for your attention
well you it's going to it's going to
accumulate through evolution but it's
not dependent it's not definitionally to
it I have this joke about methodological
creationism right I think that anything
that's given that's part of a genuine
causal explanation in developmental
biology should be something which could
exist even if the living world was
created five seconds ago as a joke by a
demon right okay it's method logically
creationist in that sense it's if no
evolution ever happened I could talk
about it but but it accumulates through
evolution yeah I I don't think it's I
think probably doesn't make sense I
think that doesn't mean that the other
notion of information isn't fine so I
don't think Creek information is what
konrad lorenz called phylogenetic
information
yeah well we should we'll talk about
this good okay good well in this case
one of the things that I found very
interesting about this this have so far
found interesting about this project is
why why nobody said okay suppose by
information that's what we mean can we
develop that into a genuine genuine
exercise in doing some science and I
don't think anybody has tried to do that
so I'm not sure that Creek I mean if the
question is what what is the heritable
source of biological specificity then I
guess I'm gonna defend the view that in
this case Crick's answer to how is
specificity passed from one cell to the
next is pretty much right at least to a
first approximation because he didn't
have epigenetics and so forth but yeah
so I guess I'm Pro Creek on this one
only I think the only thing I think is
wrong is the claim that all the
information is in the coding sequence
yeah but the the account of I mean I
here's something which again you know I
don't want to come across as somebody
who's kind of you know trying to say
that I mean I often I'm sure you you
don't think this but you know frequently
P I'll give a talk and people will say
you're one of these people who wants to
dismiss genetics right I I think that I
can't imagine any way of doing the basic
job of moving biological specificity
around without something like a template
replicating mechanism so I think Crick
identified you know an essential core
of the capacity to do that which is
these multi what I think are multipotent
templates he thought they were templates
you know with a ferry sort of rigid role
we think they'd be used in way more
interesting ways but they're still
templates and they're still at the core
and I also think that in terms of the
evolution of these systems you know I'm
again this is a thesis that not
everybody would agree with and you know
I think that lot of respect for the
people that don't agree with it but I'm
quite tempted and attracted by the view
that this should be thought of as the
ultimate evolutionary key innovation the
invention of the use of templates to
transfer biological specificity well
maybe maybe yeah but I know there
I mean totally in agreement with that I
mean so the view I've been perhaps not
entirely effective you're trying to
communicate is that you have to think
about coding sequences as a template
which has many many different meanings
which of those meanings is actualized is
a function of multiple layers of
regulatory architecture starting in the
non-coding sequences of the genome and
finishing I would argue for most
organisms in a highly structured
environment produced and it's that whole
system not just the cellular system but
also that I guess that's another idea
the large parts of the extracellular
environment which are the they are part
of the regulatory architecture and then
I was trying to go one stage further by
saying it's not just that they regulate
which potentials in the genome are
expressed but they actually contribute
to the detailed specification of the
structure of gene products they play
that can sometimes play exactly the same
causal role the underlying coding
sequence does namely making the
difference between whether one peptide
lies next to another yep
so now we're very much in agreement with
that on the other hand I guess I'm
emphasizing you know crooks in earlier
writings I've often been very skeptical
about notions of genetic information and
I think a lot of those criticisms have
missed tricks and in responding to
critics so at the moment I really am
trying to emphasize that you shouldn't
throw out the by sort of accepting the
the whole kind of epigenetic and
regulatory kind of bath water you
shouldn't ignore the fact that there's a
little baby of coding sequence floating
in there
yeah I am really interested in the idea
that so the distinction between
describing a system as in so is if
information is a an actual construct
that we're using in the model that
explains what happens then it's got a
very different status from in the sort
of example of signaling between the seed
beetle and her offspring that I
discussed right so why so what I've
tried to do is to introduce a
stipulative definition of information in
which information is a quantity that we
can actually measure in a you know a
graph theoretic representation of the
structure of a molecular system okay and
then why do I do that well here are some
things and there's a classic arguments
do to people like a virgil blanco and so
on what it's what's the value of that
well one value is that you can then look
at physically very very different
mechanisms and identify that they're
playing that their theoretical role is
exactly the same okay using this notion
of information so for me one of the
things I really want to be able to do is
to say here's here's for me a very
exciting claim okay and will seem
obvious to some people crazy to others
which shows you why it's a useful claim
all right it's that if we say in what's
the most rigorous sense in which there
was some real substance to the claim
that DNA is an informational molecule
you so look the most rigorous pin down
real science sense is captured in the
lookup table that gives you the genetic
code it's the fact that you can perturb
the order of these linear elements and
you can produce fine grain control in
the molecule okay
that's there's a real sense if there's
any real substance to the claim that
this molecule is informational
that's what we're talking about and then
I'm going to show you that I can give
you a definition of information which
captures that and that turns out to be
information in exactly that sense is
being transmitted from regulatory
regions of the genome to the site of
assembly of a biomolecule okay
that to me is really you know whereas
previously you know you get into fights
about the relative significance of
different mechanisms the fact that you
can get a currency which is you know at
the heart of what was supposed to have
been this big breakthrough in molecular
biology in the 50s as I agree it was
which runs between both of those cases I
mean that's so it's I mean that's as
often the reason for using informational
language is too abstract slightly but I
don't want to abstract so far that I'm
no longer actually talking about the
causal processes in the organism so
that's why I think it goes somewhere to
vindicating that idea that in organisms
are informational yeah right yeah well
I'm trying to I'm trying to meet the I
mean so think about my problem with the
Teela semantic information so here's a
look yeah okay there is a real this this
is a really good point to push I mean
the I think oh there there are various
different kinds of and I mean this in a
philosophical sense kinds of explanation
going on in the biological sciences one
of those kinds of explanation is current
time mechanistic we've got a whole bunch
of bits and they produce a phenomena and
we want to show how the interaction of
those bits in accordance with physical
laws generates the phenomena for me
that's the distinctive kind of
explanation of developmental biology
developmental biology explains how
putting a certain bunch of bits together
in a physical configuration produces a
phenomena what's that phenomena the life
cycle of an organism
and what I'm driving for is for
information to be the kind of thing that
configuring that kind of explanation
rather than for example in what
sometimes refer to as ultimate
explanations or unifying explanations
across different domains or something
like that I want it to be part of a you
know a good old sort of nuts and bolt
mechanistic explanation of how a
physical system changes over time and
I've achieved that by defining a sense
of information in terms of an account of
causation now I think it's completely
open for somebody to say I don't want to
use the word information for that okay I
mean Ken Watters well-known philosopher
ken thinks we should just talk about
causation here I'm all I'm going to give
you as my Carnap Ian story I'm going to
say look there's some intellectual
continuity with the common sense idea of
information that's my that's my license
to use the I word let's move on